[Musique]
merci j'ai toujours voulu être
professeur et quand je débute au 99
et bien c'est le choc je découvre mes
premiers élèves
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il manque d' enthousiasme pour
l'école et pour l'anglais certains se
demandent même ce qu'ils font là c'est
très dur à vivre quand on est soi-même
passionné mais je ne me décourage pas ce
n'est pas dans ma nature
au contraire je cherche continuellement
des réponses aux questions que je me
pose comment les aider comment les
motiver et je me rends compte que j'en
ai une d'élèves motivés c'est justin là
bas justin qui chante et qui chante en
anglais et je comprends que c'est l'une
des clés leur donner envie
alors comment faire
et bien je me dis que je vais les rendre
acteurs
il écrit des nouvelles ils échangent
avec des auteurs américains et
britanniques
ils coopèrent même avec un chercheur
britannique est un auteur français 6 jan
ils écrivent des haïkus pour étudier
shakespeare
ils sont créatifs et ils se rendent
compte
enfin je me rend compte très vite que ça
se passe très bien
il travaille il progresse mais je
rencontre un nouveau problème mes
projets sont chronophages
or il faut bien signer les bases lexique
grammaire méthodologie ne tombe pas du
ciel
c'est pourquoi je commence à partager
des documents ligne qu'ils consultent à
la maison à partir de ces documents ils
peuvent ils peuvent s'appuyer sur ces
documents
dès leur arrivée en classe
afin de pouvoir travailler de façon plus
créatives de façon plus ambitieuse en
classe sans le savoir je viens d'un vent
de réinventer vraiment la classe en
inversé qui existe déjà aux états unis
la classe inversée consiste à proposer
des sujets des textes des vidéos à la
maison afin que les élèves les
consultent et on classe ils puissent
aller plus loin mais qu'est ce qui
change vraiment et bien tout par des
élèves et de leurs besoins pour que ce
soit plus clair je vais vous expliquer
mon cheminement première étape
ma préparation de profs tout d'abord je
sélectionne une thématique
ensuite je leur propose une vidéo que
j'ai aussi à ce thème
en dernier lieu j'utilise t dead
je ne sais pas si vous connaissez des
dead oui non bon il faut découvrir ça
plus tard donc je leur propose donc
d'utiliser t dead le tête du prof qui
permet de mettre en interactivité les
élèves avec des questions des débats à
partir de la vidéo qui est téléchargé
sur le site qui a été choisi deuxième
étape leur travail à la maison
les élèves ont une mission ils doivent
travailler la vidéo la visionner
répondre aux questions mais surtout et
avant tout ils doivent échanger entre
eux sur le site des dead
par exemple ils peuvent travailler à la
maison une vidéo sur la thématique du
héros et en classe échanger sur des
extraits de gatsby le magnifique et à
partir de la vidéo
eh bien ils ont les who
si pour pouvoir définir ce héros très
particuliers si bien incarnée mesdames
par leonardo dicaprio
j'ai testé la classe inversée avec des
élèves en très grande difficulté quasi
décrocheurs avec des élèves d'un autre
niveau des élèves de sections
internationales avec des étudiants de
master enseignement avec des professeurs
avec des professeurs stagiaires et à
tous ces niveaux
ça a fonctionné la pédagogie de la
classe inversée m'a même aidé à stimuler
la créativité des élèves à leur donner
la parole
vraiment et ainsi à donner un sens à
leur apprentissage
grâce à la classe inversée deux de mes
classes
j'étais dans le nord et de mes classes
de seconde dont les élèves étaient
prioritairement issus de familles à ces
démunis ont réussi à obtenir un prix
national le prix du partenariat à
l'unesco et à ce moment là c'est pas moi
c'est eux
[Applaudissements]
donc je lui disais ils ont obtenu ce
prix et il s'est passé quelque chose
corentin l'un de mes élèves s'est écrié
quelque chose et j'aurais aimé que vous
me disiez ce que vous pensez qui s'est
écrit quand je leur annoncer ce prix à
votre avis qu'est ce qu'il sait qu'est
ce qu'il a dit corentin super ouais
merci vous voyez alors que c'est eux qui
ont travaillé moi je les lance je les
pousse un peu gelé mais c'est eux qui
travaillent donc mais oui en effet et
quoi d'autre à votre avis qu'est-ce
qu'il qu'est ce qu'il a dit corentin
nickel pareil bon bah écoute et j'aurais
adoré que corentin me dise super nickel
en fait ce qu'il a dit c'est bon on
n'est pas nul alors je combats ce mot
depuis toujours
personne n'est nulle pour qu'ils merci
c'est normal pour qu'il renonce à cette
idée mes élèves depuis toujours depuis
18 ans je fais tout ce que je peux tout
ce qui est en mon pouvoir pour les
valoriser
et c'est là que la classe inversée
m'aide énormément parce que la
créativité justement permet aux élèves
de se sentir valorisé
j'ai pu constater que mes élèves sont
heureux qu'il travaille avec un
enthousiasme incroyable à la maison
qu'ils préparent les cours sans
rechigner
alors que c'est ça quand on a peur quand
on est prof est ainsi eh bien ça permet
d'aller beaucoup plus loin en classe
pour accompagner nos enfants dans le
monde de demain
nous devons tous nous évoluer tout
simplement nous devons tous penser à
l'avenir de ces jeunes
nos cours doivent s'inscrire dans la
logique actuelle celle des compétences
du 21e siècle les compétences du fermier
ème siècle ce sont justement celles que
la classe inversée m'a permis de mettre
en place dans ma classe la collaboration
la créativité la communication la
citoyenneté les ans culturel et social
les compétences liées aux nouvelles
technologies le développement du sens
critique
s'adapter être autonome avoir confiance
en soi
voilà ce qu'il est important de
développer chez nos jeunes pour leur
réussite mais surtout pour autre chose
pour leur bonheur c'est bien c'était un
peu aussi pour leur bien-être
apprendre à apprendre et oser dans ce
monde en perpétuel mouvement
voilà ce qui compte à mes yeux quand
j'enseigne n'oublions pas que d'ici 20
ans la plupart des métiers que nous
exerçons auront disparu et que ceux qui
les auront remplacé
eh bien nous ignorons même leur nom
alors osons ozon tous aux ont innové
avec et pour eux merci
[Musique]
on